his queen back swap the queens and then
this pawn will match up and win let's go
back to the players is magnus gonna find
the winning move bringing his queen back
and trading off the black queen
ivanka does that just win on the spot it
wins on the spot and it's on the board
he's found it and look at this it's a
porn race but white pawns are gonna be
just
one move quicker
and uh there we go white's gonna
continue pushing that pawn in the center
i think the queens there's tension there
but it's as if they don't exist so the
queens have traded i think the black
king is might even get checkmated i hope
we see checkmate on the board
is about to allow this two queens and
then magnus will deliver checkmate
oh no he's going to resign is he before
checkmate no allows the tech mate show
us the checkmate
vladislav ah
well
what a start though for magnus carlsen
in the milwaukee championship 2022 what
a win and what a game what a game it
really heated up at the end there yeah
and we said it the computer said 0.0 but
if you have less than one minute left in
a difficult really complicated angle